nicki minaj is giving a glimpse into her
life as a mama bear to her one-year-old
son she calls papa bear and it's the
most adorable thing
ever yes absolutely the rapper shares
this cute video of the little one in a
stroller as they play peek-a-boo
together and when nicki tries to get his
attention this happens
[Music]
now you want to act like you ain't seen
my i see you
i see you and it may seem like papa is
ignoring his mama but he's really just
teasing her
i see
i see
the super bass rapper explains in the
caption that her son makes her call him
just so he can ignore her she says at
first i used to really think he was just
zoning out and not hearing me and i got
a little worried but no it's just him
thinking he a little comedian or
something i mean it's pretty obvious
right the sweet back and forth continues
in another clip as nikki films her
husband kenneth petty who can't help but
point out the resemblance between the
two what are you saying what you doing
what are you doing
you see that right there you look just
like your mother right there boy just
like your mom
turns out papa bear really is just like
his mama last month while chatting with
james corden on the late late show nikki
revealed the little guy has a bit of her
signature sass he's just walking around
telling everybody grown adults what are
you doing what are you doing
what are you doing like if i'm feeding
him his food and i take a little bit too
long with the next spoon he goes hey
john
hey john hey john
i'm like what are you doing i'm i'm
getting feeding you
it's crazy but the grammy winner loves
it and feels very fortunate to be his
mom i think motherhood has made me see
more good in
people see more good in the universe
makes makes makes you a little bit more
of a forgiving person not that you
forgive people and you want everybody
around you because i've forgiven people
recently and not necessarily one of them
in my space but just have peace move on
god bless you
but because when i look at my son i'm
reminded i'm reminded that i'm so so
blessed every every we are so blessed
y'all
[Music]